ソフトクリームの持ち手ってあるじゃないですか
まぁ、俗に言う「コーン」ってんですけど...
まぁ、もちろんなんかシュガーコーンとか
味が付いてると
話がまた別になると思うんですけども
この普通のコーン
アイスに付いてるただのコーンって
これ...
いや、もちろん持ち手ってゆうのは
分かってるんですけども
このコーンていう存在意義がちょっと僕...
ぃ...いまいち理解できてなくて！
も、ホントにアイス食う為の取っ手だけの代物であり
味も決してそんなあるわけでもなく
これマジでもう、あの...
「無」なんですよ！「無」！！
ソフトクリームをこの、持つ
あの役割以外はもう「無」なんで
食ってもあんまり感覚がないと思ってるんですよ。僕
てことは！...
無限に食えるんじゃね？
ソフトクリームのこの持ち手の
コーンカップ２００...何個準備しました
全部、食えるんじゃね？
私は思った。
こんだけ軽い物だったら、多分...
無限に食えるんじゃねぇか？
本気でコーンカップ何個食えるか
ちょっと試してみようと思います
もしこれがホントに意味のない代物であったら
僕は無限に食えることが出来る
逆にこの２００個程度で
僕が「オエッ...」っとかなってたら...
ん、まぁまぁまぁ...
食いまぁす！！！
よし、もうくもう（？）
もう、もう食わせて頂きますよ
いただきます。
っへｗｗ
すごいなんか ２個食ったんですけど
全然、お腹が膨れません
これマジで無限に食える説あるぞこれ！
４つ目にして早くも気付いたことがあります！
これ！
なんか甘いな...
なんか ほ、ほんのり甘い気がします
え～でも砂糖使われてないんだよなぁ...
すげぇこれ！
食うば食う程味の美味しさが分かるパターンだこれは
え、コーンって美味いのなぁ
え、全然いけますこれ！
え...
ｸｴﾙｿﾞｫｫ!?!?
あぁ...
いや...
なんか別に
お腹がいっぱいとかってわけじゃないんですけど...
噛むのがホントにキツい
バリバリ
つらぁい...；；
けどまだ...
OKです！！👍
はぁはぁはぁはぁ...
すっ...こんだけ食うと飽きてきたなぁ...
２５個ぐらい食うと
ちょっと飽きますね
でも、お腹はまだ全然食えるんで
もっと食っていきたいと思います
あのおおおおぉぉぉぉぉ....
えぇ...今、３１個ぐらい食べたんですけども...
ｵ"ｴ"ｪ...
不味くないしお腹も全然食えるんですけど...
ｱｷﾁｯﾀ...
味の飽きっちゃった...ｗｗ
やっぱりコーンってのは
アイスがないとやっぱこう
なんか成立しないようなとこがあるんでちょっと...
アイス乗せて食べていきましょう！
ｱｧ...ww ｱｱｧｨ...ww
ｷｬｯｷｬｯ!
お”お”お”お”う”め”え”え”
やっぱアイスと食ってなんぼだなぁ
ちょっとこの作戦で食っていきます！
ｳ"ｴ"ｴ"...ｺｫ...
ぅえ！？
マジ？血が出てきた...
なぜかアイスクリームに血がついています！
多分わかんないっすけどコーンが鋭すぎてね
口が出血してるんだと思います
くるしぃ...；；
やべぇ...
結構、大きいやつなんですけど
もうだいぶないです...
しっくたぁ！！
ぉい、まって...
ｵｴ''...
もう無理かも☆
【検証結果】...
む’’げん”じゃ”あ”り”ま”ぜん”でじだぁ”！！
クッソォォオオ！！
い”げる”どお”も”っだの”に”ぃ”！！
食えなっかった敗因がいくつかありましてぇ...
まずね、味に飽ききてしまいます。
コーンというのもやはりコーンなりの味がありまして...
非常に...
お飽き致しました。
ここ１年はもう食いたくないと思います。
味に飽きたからってこの７００kcalあるアイス...
ほぼ食ってしまいました。
それでちょっとお腹も膨れてしまった。
且つぅ、
コーンがすごい痛い！
このままだといいんですけど、
なんかこういうチクチクになったまま
口に運ぶと刺さっちゃってぇ
血が出ました☆
もっと食えたと思うんですけども
あの僕はとりあえず５７個で限界でした...
全部食べられると思ったんですけど...
無理でした...
すいませんでした！！